the most freeing things
that white people can do or
actually any human being on the planet
could do right now is to just say of
course i'm racist of course i'm racist
our society speaks racism it has spoken
racism since we were born
well it seems that portland kindergarten
teachers took that to heart because new
teaching materials that are obtained
exclusively by chris ruffo expose how
race has now infected the already
sexually obsessed curriculum that's
inside the portland public schools now i
want to show you just a couple of these
slides one suggests that even the word
trans
can be racist
as it is the language preferred by the
colonizers instead they recommend adding
something called two spirits
to be exclusively indigenous
and if that isn't bad enough one of
their slides glamorizes the act of
rioting as an acceptable reaction to
anything perceived to be
white colonization here now is chris
ruffo manhattan institute senior fellow
chris um
so now gender
is colonized and i don't really even
understand the trans thing at all i'm
not following that but what the heck is
going on here kids as young as five
yeah exactly so what's happening is that
portland public schools has taken
academic queer theory and turned it into
a k-5 pedagogy
they're teaching kids that some boys can
have vaginas some girls can have penises
they're encouraging them to adopt
synthetic sexual identities such as
genderqueer non-binary and pansexual
and then they're telling kids that this
is part of a political movement it was
critical race theory last year it's
queer theory this year you have to get
on board you have to reshape your
identity according to this ideology and
then by the end of fifth grade they
actually have them reading out
commitments to commit their lives to
radical left-wing activism by the ages
of 10 and 11 years old
now in this slide the portland public
education system
trying to demonize the idea of gender
altogether saying that gender is
something that adults came up with
to sort people into groups now
chris they're they're trying
to erase the idea of the two sexes like
this is binary completely that's way out
the window
exactly and the best way to think of
this is critical race theory divides the
world into racial groups and saying that
they're fundamentally against each other
oppressing one another they're trying to
do the same thing with sex saying that
white heterosexual men have always
oppressed
racial and sexual minorities it's the
same kind of basic marxist theory now
applied to both race and gender it's
happening in portland it's happening all
over this country in our k-12 public
schools
now this next slide you obtained
i think is the most disturbing
describing gender dysphoria it says if a
kid is still figuring out their i love
that their gender and needs time to
figure out what body parts shapes and
expressions they want they can take
hormone blockers that cause puberty and
give them
that pause puberty and give them time to
figure out who they are
so chris they're pushing the idea of
medically altering your body on little
kids
that's that's you know what could go
wrong there
these are our you know fourth and fifth
graders and they're telling them they
can start puberty blockers uh they can
get double mastectomies for the girls
they can adopt these synthetic sexual
identities such as trans and non-binary
and all doing all of this without
notifying parents
everyone should be on guard for this
ideology into schools because it's
coming it's coming to a school near you
now i know portland is a liberal place
but
do most parents and you know
immigrant parents is this what they want
for their kids
it's absolutely not it's deeply
unpopular and actually just minutes ago
after i broke this story the
administrators at portland public
schools started furiously deleting all
of these documents from their websites
from the internet because they can only
do this in secrecy they can only do this
by hiding it from parents by hiding it
from the public but when we shine a
light on it when parents show up at
those school board meetings and start to
make their voices heard these ideologies
shrink and crumble because they can't
stand the light of day they're evil
they're harming kids and parents have to
stand up and fight back to make sure
that no more lives are ruined by queer
theory and these harmful ideologies
no but remember merrick garland is going
to make sure they're all these parents
are considered domestic extremists if
they get a little heated at these school
board meetings which a lot of moms and
dads if that when they see this stuff
they're going to get a little heated so
now they're going to have to be worried
about being categorized as domestic
terrorists so that's that's the other
thing we're dealing with chris
invaluable service you provided tonight
thank you so much hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else